right-hander vince velasquez who finally
gets to make his second start of the
season ronald lacuna stepping into the
right-hand batters box swinging a miss
he blew it by him there fastball got him
acuna goes down on strikes here's dansby
swanson who's old for his last 11. and
dansby got nail with a breaking ball and
he hit swanson while ahead in the count
and the braves have their first base
runner and here's freeman
oh they had swanson leading and he got
back reece says take a look oh it got it
got him yeah yeah he's out
well that helps a great deal it sure
does because now you have freeman with
nobody on in two outs swing and a miss
got a way out front of that changeup and
he picked up his second strikeout of the
day young husker inaudible who makes his
debut as a starter for the braves today
he has pitched in the big leagues before
and he made his debut against
philadelphia
strike three called on the outside
corner so inaudible comes back to get
the phillies lead off man
and here is rhys hoskins the man that
iwa struck out for his first in the
major leagues hoskins hits that one high
in the air toward left but that's
playable for marcel and
no problem two quick outs so here's
harper he's seven for 24 on the season
that's on the ground right side freeman
will shovel and the braves take care of
bryce harper and the phillies second
inning and marcel ozuna leads off for
atlanta there's a hard hit ball by ozuna
headed for the left field corner boy he
went up and lashed that baby
and ozuna is going to chug towards
second and slide in ahead of the throw
and the braves have their first hit from
ozuna it's a leadoff double here in the
second inning nick marquez the dh here
for the first game swing and a miss so
marcakis is dismissed
strikeout number three for velasquez
ozuna at second with one out and here's
johan camargo camargo draws the walk
there are two on for ade echeverria out
to right field toward the line
harper says he has it ozuna's tagging
harper's throw
cut off by gregorius
that holds mizuna at second base two
outs here in the second and now two on
two out for tyler flowers
and he lost him the bases are loaded for
ender's second walk of the inning and
this long second continues for vince
velazquez brian price coming out to find
out what's going on with velasquez
they've seen this movie over and over
sacks full two out in ciarte at the
plate rolls over on one to second base
neal walker's up with it and the inning
is over it took 27 pitches he had to
work aside and lead off double and two
walks he gets out of it though
freddie freeman just six pitches to get
two outs for velazquez would be nice to
keep that trend going smoked into center
field and that's going to get down and
roll past roman quinn who tried to make
a diving catch
and freddie freeman's on his way to
second with a two-out hit and now an rbi
chance for marcel ozuna swing this he
struck him out fastball got him and for
vince velasquez strikeout number four on
the afternoon now men are at second and
third with one out the phillies will
pull adam hazley back and have andrew
mccutchen bat against matsuk that one is
hit softly left side picked up by
camargo he throws the rudder out but a
run scores and the phillies take the
lead not much for hoskins to hit there
he draws the walk and the table is set
now for bryce harper
left on left match-up the one-two pitch
he's swung on and missed he struck him
out so matic neutralizes harper damage
limited to one run now one-on-one out
for echeveria and the 3-2 runner goes
again swing and a miss to throw on down
and it's in plenty of time
tag applied by neal walker and marchakis
is gunned down a strikeout throw him out
double play that's just what the doctor
ordered for
gene segura swipes second base and is in
scoring position with two down for
walker pitch on the way that's hit high
in the air to right center field acuna
and inciarte both there and ronald
squeezes out number three in the
phillies leave a man stranded at second
base and one down here in the brave half
of the fifth inning back to the top of
the order toronto to cuny last eight
games against the phillies three homers
nine rbis
nice to see him unload here and turn the
game around with one swing of the bat
swing and a drive that's hammered down
the line it is gone ronald does it with
one swing of the bat
and just like that atlanta has taken the
lead and the braves
all of a sudden enjoy an advantage and
they do it against the phillies pen so
they are now loaded for adam duvall get
the right-handed batter up against the
southpaw this is where that three
battery rule might come in to play la
because oregon has to face this batter
you cannot come out great opportunity
for the braves and the first pitch is
rocking it down the line that is off the
base of the wall it's a bases clearing
double for adam duvall on the very first
pitch and the braves have broken this
game open one down as quinn advances
over to third base back to the top of
the order to andrew mccutchen flyball
hit to center field on the run is
incertained back he goes he's under it
he'll reach up and make the catch letter
high tagging it third is roman quinn
he'll come home and score it's a 5-2
ball game so here's gregorius and he
represents the tying run in the bottom
of the fifth inning curveball popped up
and gregorius just drops his bat in
frustration in foul ground freeman is
under it he squeezes out number three
and will smith figures it out and gets
out of the jam and mark malenson will
try and nail down game one with the
branch leading 5-2 two down here's bryce
harper fly ball toward left and that's
gonna do it the braves come back with a
five run fifth and beat the phillies in
game one